today we're talking about AIML trainings
the people of Google cloud and committed
use discounts I'm Anu and welcome to
this week in Cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news tech companies
are ramping up the search for highly
skilled data analytics AIML engineers
and professionals with a race to AI
accelerating the crunch they are looking
for cloud experts who can successfully
build test run and manage complex tools
and infrastructure all for training
deploying and serving machine learning
models
roles include data analysts data
Engineers data scientists and the list
goes on this Workforce takes vast
amounts of data and puts it to work
solving top business challenges
including increasing customer
satisfaction production quality and
operational efficiency
learn more on the blog about why and
what trainings are available so you can
set yourself up and your team for
success
MK Palmore is a director in Google
Cloud's information security office a
group that works with private and public
sector organizations to understand and
guard against cyber security threat he
came to Google cloud in 2021 from Palo
Alto networks which he joined following
three decades in the Marines and the FBI
check out the blog to learn more about
his story his career and thoughts for
the future saving money never goes out
of style today many of our customers use
compute engine resource based committed
use discounts or cuds to help them save
on steady state compute usage within a
specific machine family and region as
part of our commitment to offer more
flexible and easy ways for you to manage
your spend we now offer a new type of
committed use discount for compute
engine flexible cuds
flexible cugs are spend based
commitments that offer predictable and
simple flat rate discounts that apply
across multiple VM families and regions
supported VM families and more details
on how to get started on the blog if you
want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet at us we'll see
you in the cloud